my first experience in Monterey Park is
I moved from Gardena and after school my
friends were just walking home A car
pulled up and they're like where the
[__] you're from and I'm like I just
moved here from garden
a that's a good answer though good thing
you sounded confident I was like I
didn't know that they were asking me
what gang I was from why are these guys
yelling at us and then they started
slamming Snapple bottles they had empty
slapple bottles they said it from
Gardena and then it's like raining
Snapple bottles and they're exploding
and I'm just [__] running like Oh I
thought
[Laughter]
they had like Sobe bottles back yes so
big dude those are long it's probably
easy
I saw it bro dogs like fruity drinks huh
you see the flavor you're like I think
I'm good strawberry kiwi yeah strong